Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
This is the second of my videos on the Doctor
Strange post-credits scenes.
In my first video, I discussed the mid-credits
scene from the film which teases a major plot
point from an upcoming Marvel Phase 3 movie,
but in this video I'm going to discuss the
final post-credits scene that appears right
at the end of the movie after all the credits
have rolled.
Just so you're aware, if you haven't seen
Doctor Strange yet, there is a major spoiler
here for a future movie, so if you want to
avoid that you can check out my spoiler-free
review of the film right here.
The scene opens with a hooded figure walking
into a workshop where Jonathan Pangborn is
working.
Pangborn asks "can I help you?" and the hooded
figure takes off his hood, revealing himself
as Mordo.
Mordo replies: "I carried you to Kamar-Taj
on a stretcher.
Look at you now Pangborn."
Just to recap: Pangborn is the paralysed man
who Doctor Strange refused to meet when he
was a neurosurgeon as he said he was untreatable.
However, after his own accident, Strange met
with Pangborn and learned that Pangborn had
discovered the power of magic at Kamar-Taj
and was using it to heal himself so he could
live his life without being paralysed.
As for Mordo, he starts the film as Doctor
Strange's ally, but by the end of the movie
is furious at Strange for using the Eye of
Agamotto to manipulate time.
And on top of that, Mordo is also angry because
he discovered that the Ancient One was using
power from the Dark Dimension to live longer
than would normally be possible for a human
being.
Ok, back to the post-credits scene: Pangborn
senses there's something wrong about Mordo,
so reaches for a crowbar.
He asks Mordo what he can do for him.
Mordo explains that he's been away for several
months and had a revelation that "the true
purpose of a sorcerer is to twist things out
of their proper shape, stealing power, perverting
nature, like you."
Pangborn replies that he's stolen nothing
and that the power he holds is his own.
Mordo retorts ominously that "Power has a
purpose."
Pangborn, who now realises Mordo has evil
intent, tries to attack him with the crowbar,
but Mordo reaches into Pangborn's stomach
and extracts a yellow light causing Pangborn
to collapse, his body now shaking as he's
lost the magic he used to fight his paralysis.
Mordo then says he now understands what is
wrong with the world, which is that there
are too many sorcerers.
The scene ends and cuts to the words "Doctor
Strange will return."
So, this scene sets up a possible Doctor Strange
sequel and a villainous role for Mordo in
the future MCU.
In the comics, Mordo studied with the Ancient
One, but had nefarious objectives, and in
this final post-credits scene, we get to see
his character tie up with his traditional
depiction as a villain in the comics.
In a Doctor Strange sequel, some of the plot
could revolve around Mordo trying to rid the
world of sorcerers, for example, by taking
their powers like he did with Pangborn and
amassing them for himself, getting ever more
powerful.
Or what about this for a potential sequel
idea involving Mordo?
Strange obviously succeeded in angering Dormammu
in the movie by trapping him in a time loop
and forcing him to agree to end his assault
on Strange's world and never come back.
Well, Strange also drew the wrath of Dormammu
in the Strange Tales comics when Doctor Strange
told Dormammu: 'you must vow never to invade
the earth'; and Dormammu agreed though he
was determined to get revenge on Strange.
Then later in the comics, Dormammu got around
that agreement by using Mordo as a proxy,
telling Mordo, 'I shall give you power without
limits so you may destroy Doctor Strange'.
So, perhaps we'll see Mordo ally with Dormammu
in a similar way in a Doctor Strange movie
sequel.
Or Mordo could come back before then, for
instance, in Avengers: Infinity War, if he
gets recruited by Thanos to help him recover
the Infinity Stones.
By the way, I also felt there was an interesting,
unintended, parallel between the post-credits
scene in Doctor Strange and the mid-credits
scene in the Green Lantern movie where Mark
Strong's Sinestro, who's previously been on
the Green Lantern's side, takes off his green
ring and puts on the yellow ring signalling
his transformation into a villain, as well
as setting up a potential Green Lantern sequel
that never was.
So, that was the post-credits scene for Doctor
Strange.
Were you excited to see Mordo turn to the
dark side and fulfil his comic-book villain
role?
And what would you like to see in a Doctor
Strange sequel?
If you haven't seen it yet, you can check
out my breakdown of the mid-credits scene
here and do make sure you're subscribed and
you've got your notifications turned on for
Flicks And The City for a chance to win this
awesome Doctor Strange book which I'll be
giving away on my easter egg video.
You might also like to check out my Doctor
Strange playlist which will feature my easter
egg breakdown, my movie review, WTF facts
about the film and also interviews with the
cast.
Click either of the links below to check those
out.
And if you liked this, I really appreciate
you hitting those like and share buttons.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!